[Applause]
as a quirky Nintendo take on fighting
games arms doesn't start off on the
right foot
it's unique fighting mechanics are hard
to get used to and learning it's unusual
controls and cadence can initially be
frustrating but once you wrap your head
around the basics you begin to recognize
what it takes to win clumsy punches
become complex dodges encounters and
reading and reacting to your opponent
come naturally as you grow more
comfortable with arms peculiar pacing if
you can get past its unavoidable
learning curve you'll find that arms
packs a fighting challenge that's unlike
anything you've ever played before and
it's fun in ways you wouldn't expect
[Music]
spring-loaded punches are the center of
arms combat your fighters arms have an
incredibly long reach and take time to
retract you're encouraged to play with
motion controls with a joi con in each
hand but that introduces a dissonance
between the length of your in-game arm
and your real-life arm by the time
you're physically ready to punch again
your virtual arm is still on its return
trip it's easier to learn simple punches
and timing with traditional controls via
the pro controller which allow for more
precise movements the timing of your
punches grabs and blocks is critical
punch with your left arm too soon after
punching with your right and you'll be
left open and vulnerable until they
return there's a rock-paper-scissors
element to all of this - blocking stops
punches grabs over power blocks and
punches deflect grabs being able to read
the speed of a punch and block before it
hits or sidestep and throw a punch of
your own is tricky and learning how to
do it is an unavoidable but frustrating
hurtle arms can feel sluggish at first
but once you put in the time to
understand its distinct give-and-take
you're freed up to confidently dodge -
and jump around the battlefield
one of the great things about arms that
you don't have to learn combos or other
complex inputs that characterize most
fighting games however beyond building a
strong understanding of when to act and
when to hold back you will need to
understand how the game's various
equippable arms can impact your
strategies and tactics in battle you can
pick out different arm configurations
before entering a match and they come
with special properties like disabling
your opponent's arms or freezing their
entire body in place in addition to
their individual physicality each
fighter has a unique ability twin-tailed
can slow opponents punches in midair
while ribbon girl keeps a handy double
jump in her back pocket
so while arms isn't a mechanically
complex fighting game it does require
that you think on your feet and pay
attention to who you're facing off
against and the individual strengths
each character brings into a match yet
for all the knowledge and skill you
acquire while continually playing arms
you may find that your control scheme of
choice has the biggest impact on your
effectiveness in battle even if both
options come with notable caveats motion
controls lack the precision of playing
with a pro controller but the person
playing with analog sticks will have to
manage curving punches and moving around
with the same stick a less than ideal
scenario nonetheless it's rare that a
person throwing punches in real life
manages to beat the player with both
hands on a stationary controller
[Music]
arms is without a doubt at its best with
two players facing off using the same
controls single player arms is a little
less exciting with a sharp difficulty
curve in the loss of a living breathing
adversary partially deflating the other
eyes fascinating combat with or without
a human opponent you can hop into extra
modes to try out your moves under new
circumstances such as target practice
and arm style volleyball these
diversions are better as warm-ups or
palate cleansers between fights they're
treated like mini games and don't
necessitate the same adaptability as
fights themselves once you figure out
the best way to win it volleyball for
example you won't have to change your
strategy much to continue winning
[Music]
[Music]
arms is a strong substantial fighting
game that takes a while to really hit
its stride its barrier to entry is
unlike anything else in the genre but
it's one worth tackling in order to get
at the game's fascinating take on
fighting it may not have the same skill
requirement as other fighting games but
the flexibility and fast thinking it
requires secures it as one that works on
its own terms and opens the genre up to
a wider audience
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you